Speaker 1: I want to start today
going back to the Pandora papers now,
the Pandora papers are different than the Panama
Papers, the Pandora papers, as we talked about,
what was it now? I guess it must have been about
about five weeks ago or something like that.
The beginning of October. The Pandora papers are
these leaks about 12 million different documents,
and they it was an undertaking involving more than
600 journalists in more than 115 countries. It was
all organized or data obtained by the ICJ. That's
the International Consortium of Investigative
Journalists in Washington, D.C. They worked
with all these different media organizations.
It was a massive I mean, it's an incredible
accomplishment journalistically to even do such
a big project. It's a huge project. And also,
it was huge in that it exposed hidden wealth,
it exposed money laundering, it exposed tax
avoidance and much of it by the world's rich,
the world's powerful. Many of the elites, as they
are often known. We now have a specific story
about consequences thanks to the Pandora papers.
Now consequences. But it's sort of like when Trump
was impeached by the House, it was a consequence,
but we knew there would be no conviction. Sort of
similar in this comes to us from the country of
Chile, the Guardian reporting that the Chilean
president has been impeached over the revelations
in the Pandora papers. Now it's impeach impeached
by the lower house, not expected to be convicted,
similar to Donald Trump's impeachment. I'll tell
you that up front, but we're going to get to that
in a moment. Chile's President Sebastian Pinera
has been impeached by the lower House of
Congress, setting up a trial in the nation's
Senate over allegations that he favored the
sale of a family property while in office.
The vote to impeach passed, but barely it had 78
votes in one hundred and fifty five member Chamber
of Deputies. There was one of the craziest things
is there was like a real, not a filibuster, but
there was one of these marathon sessions twenty
hours. Sixty seven legislators voted against,
including several members of the opposition. Some
abstained or were absent, and 78 voted in favor.
Pinera is unlikely to be removed by the 43 member
upper house, where the opposition has only 24 of
the 29 votes, so he he has the overwhelming
majority of the votes in the Upper House.
The trial will come in the heat of a general
election campaign first round of elections set
for the 21st of November. The term ends on the
11th of March. Chile does not permit presidential
reelection two consecutive term, so term limited
out anyway. So what's at issue here? This was not
like the most explosive of the revelations, to be
totally clear, but the leaked documents revealed
a controversial deal to sell the Pinera family's
stake in the Dominga Mining Project and a contract
found by the project suggested the first
hundred and thirty eight million of the sale
was made through shell companies registered in the
BVI eyes the British Virgin Islands. The documents
suggest the final payment at the mine sale in 2011
hinged on the government declining to declare its
location in north central Chile a nature preserve.
So it's sort of like cronyism favors. It's
it's everything we know. Pinera said he had not
been involved in managing the companies and didn't
even realize the connection. The government
at that time was headed by Pinera didn't do
so. Despite appeals from environmentalists.
The president's office noted last month that
Panetta's first term as president from 2010 to
2014 hadn't started when the sale was agreed to,
and that prosecutors and courts decided in 2017.
No crime was committed and the president wasn't
involved and all taxes were paid, and that his
holdings are now in a blind trust, et cetera, et
cetera. However, they did ultimately get
the majority needed in the lower House
for this impeachment. So what what do we take
from this? What do we make of it? On the one hand,
we can say, and I think it's accurate to
say activism and investigative journalism
have real impacts in the real world. It's one
of the first examples of the Pandora papers
actually being that they are not just these sort
of like what would what would we call it? It's
not disaster porn, it's not elite porn. It's sort
of like these are not merely wow. Look at this,
look at the money and look at the things that
they do it. It led to a real consequence of sorts.
That being said, you could argue this is kind
of a token move that there is no way in hell
that is actually going to be removed because the.
At trial in the Upper House is going to say, no,
we are not removing him. He can't run in the next
election anyway and is down to the last four and a
half or so months there, so that's a fair position
as well. This is kind of a token move for me.
The takeaway is this was an extraordinarily well
carried out project of investigative journalism.
It exposes that even many of the supposedly
good guys in power are still doing
all of the same things that the so-called bad
guys are doing when it comes to cronyism and
money and deals and the like. And it furthers
for me the importance of these kinds of projects
continuing to be supported and continuing to do
their work. We, you know, you look at history
and whether it's Woodward and Bernstein with
Nixon or whatever example you want to pick.
Investigative journalism exposes important things,
and it's one of the first things that goes when
media organizations say we've got to tighten
the belt. And as I've explained to you before,
if you are a media organization and you are given
the option of OK, we're going to do investigative
journalism, which means funding reporters who
have to do in many cases, significant travel
paying sometimes for different aspects of
conducting the investigative journalism
for a story that they might work on for a year or
more. And we might get something out of it, but we
might get not get something out of it. That's one
option. As a media entity, you can pay for that
or on the complete other side of the spectrum,
you say, I'm going to hire writers who will sit
at home and just rewrite articles from other
news organizations, adding our spin, not naming
anybody, but that's a business model. You have
a website, you don't do original reporting.
You say, Oh, look, here's a story reported by
The Washington Post in the New York Times. Let me
put a different headline on it. Quote from it and
publish it and run ads on that. That is dirt cheap
to do compared to this type of investigative
journalism, which can take months or years.
And we don't really get much out of the latter,
but we get a lot out of the former. But the former
costs a lot more. So this is also related to the
reality of of sort of the industry of journalism
at this point in time. Interesting. I don't think
this will lead to much in terms of the Chilean
president, but it is at least a consequence,
a consequence from the Pandora papers.